und jetzt aus oldenburg zugeschaltet
amira mohamad ali die fraktionschefin
der linkspartei guten morgen
guten morgen 30 milliarden an
entlastungen hat die bundesregierung
schon auf den weg gebracht über ein
drittes paket wird gerade verhandelt der
vizekanzler robert habeck hat uns heute
morgen im interview noch einmal gesagt
dass diejenigen die weniger verdienen
stärker unterstützt werden müssen als
diejenigen die viel verdienen ist ganz
ihre linie oder
ja das ist nicht wirklich im grundsatz
richtig wobei man auch sagen muss die
menschen mit geringem einkommen brauchen
in der tat besondere unterstützung aber
diese inflation und die extrem hohe
preise treffen ja immer weitere
schichten auch in der datei der auch in
der mittelschicht und auch den menschen
muss geholfen werden nun gibt es eben
diese große entlastungs debatte jetzt
ihr rezept das der linkspartei unter
anderem ein winter geld für alle
haushalte also 1500 euro für jeden
haushalt und 600 euro für jedes weitere
haushaltsmitglied also wirklich für
jeden haushalt
ja das ist dringend notwendig gebrauchen
flächendeckende entlastungen die die
tatsächlichen kosten auch abdecken aber
wieso denn nicht dann genauer
zielführend auf diejenigen die wirklich
nicht so viel haben wieso soll dann
jetzt alle wieder was bekommen
da wissen sie das problem trifft ja die
allermeisten menschen sehr hart ja es
gibt einen gewissen teil i sag mal mehr
menschen die jetzt millionäre sind die
würden das ja auch entsprechend
steuerlich wieder abführen aber ich
finde es schon bemerkenswert dass die
bundesregierung immer wieder darüber
redet dann müsste ich jetzt zielgenau
helfen und besonders diejenigen mit
kleinen einkommen entlasten das
geschieht dann aber gar nicht die ganzen
steuerentlastungen zum beispiel die
jetzt kommen ich meine furchtbar viel
ist es nicht aber das was da kommt
trifft die menschen mit ganz kleinem
einkommen oder betrifft die fast
überhaupt nicht weil die praktisch keine
steuern zahlen das heißt es wird immer
viel darüber geredet dann müsste jetzt
zielgenau helfen das geschieht aber
nicht und deswegen machen wir jetzt ein
vorschlag der einfach allen helfen würde
als praktischen vorschlag wir können
darüber reden ob man es für gewisse sehr
hohe einkommen dann nicht auszahlt
können wir gerne darüber diskutieren
aber das ist entlastungen braucht und
breite bevölkerung das ist für uns sehr
klar ich verstehe nicht wie sie
einerseits kritisieren dass die
bundesregierung nicht zielgenau ein
paket formuliert sie aber für alle
gleichzeitig fordern das ist doch auch
nicht zielgenau
die das hab ich jetzt haben sie mich
vielleicht missverstanden was ich meine
ist die bundesregierung spricht immer
viel davon das zielgenau gefördert
werden soll aber das geschieht dann
nicht das sind doch in erster linie
nebelkerzen das erste entlassung paket
mit 300 euro was was versteuert werden
muss was viele gar nicht bekommen haben
rentnerinnen und rentner studierende und
jetzt gibt es teilweise
steuerentlastungen die auch nur wieder
ein teil der bevölkerung bekommt und
diejenigen die es besonders brauchen
haben davon praktisch nichts das ist der
falsche weg und jetzt muss man mal
anfangen bisschen zu klotzen und nicht
immer nur um zu klettern vor allen
dingen nicht mehr nur anzukündigen
sondern endlich auch etwas zu tun und da
hatte schied einfach viel zu wenig und
wie gesagt natürlich kann man darüber
reden ob man besonders hohe einkommen
jetzt entsprechend nicht mit den 1500
euro versorgt das ist vielleicht auch
sinnvoll aber wir müssen jetzt endlich
mal handeln und es geht nicht dass so
viele menschen im regen stehen gelassen
werden die situation wird immer
dramatischer sie fordern auch keine
kündigungen also keinen strom oder auch
keine gar sperren das soll gesetzlich
geregelt werden und wer sorgt dafür dass
dann vermieter und stadtwerke irgendwann
an ihr geld kommen weil das muss ja auch
weiterlaufen dieses geschäft
selbstverständlich wir reden darüber
dass strom und gas sperren verboten
werden das bedeutet dass diejenigen die
ihre rechnungen nicht bezahlen können
das nie die nicht in kalten dunklen
wohnung sitzen gelassen werden darüber
reden wir es geht nicht darum dass
generell alle befreit werden ihre gas
und stromrechnung zu bezahlen natürlich
nicht es geht darum dass nicht
abgeschaltet werden kann und
selbstverständlich haben vermieter und
vermieterin genau wie die stadtwerke die
möglichkeit die forderungen die
entstanden sind ganz normal zu betreiben
wie jeder andere forderung auch das
selbstverständlich müssen die ihr geld
bekommen was wir eben verhindern wollen
ist dass den menschen strom und gas
abgeschaltet wird weil das einfach
dramatische folgen hat und da steht
vollkommen außer verhältnis zu dem was
die gegenforderung ist wir wissen dass
eine wohnung ohne gas die ist praktisch
unbewohnbar das ein riesenproblem es
geht nicht ja irgendwo wird irgendwas
immer fehlen wahrscheinlich in dieser
situation frau elli die linke ruft zu
montagsdemonstrationen in der krise auf
wie wollen sie verhindern dass
rechtsradikale ihre proteste
instrumentalisieren
mein name ist mohammed ali und zur frage
wir rufen auf zu protesten gegen die
hohen energiekosten wir wollen wir
umverteilungen wir wollen dass die
großen energiekonzerne die von dieser
krise profitieren und zwar in
milliarden-höhe dass die entsprechend
stärker besteuert werden damit mehr geld
für die allgemeinheit da ist das sind
alles dinge das thema umverteilung damit
hat die afg und konsorten wirklich gar
nichts zu tun die sind der auffassung
dass die situation deswegen so schlecht
ist er für die bürgerinnen und bürger
weil deutschland soviel
entwicklungshilfe leistet und so ein
blödsinn also in anderen worten wir
werden inhaltlich uns positionieren und
damit rechts wirklich nichts zu tun
amira mohammed ali die fraktionschefin
der linkspartei im bundestag danke für
das interview heute morgen